foreign
special Iran is brutally suppressing
protests across the country the
demonstrators demand more freedom from
the strict theocracy run by the
country's Elites especially looking for
freedom for women too but behind the
suppression lies a shadow economy
funding the state's political Security
Forces it's a story of corruption
economic mismanagement a small circle of
leaders and their families pocketing
Millions while preaching humility and
worst of all carrying out violent
brutality against ordinary citizens
we won't be navigating this topic alone
Kasra Arabi is Iran program lead for the
Tony Blair Institute for Global change
thank you very much for joining us um
castra um before we look at the shadowy
economics funding Iran's brutal
Crackdown
um let's turn to the the current
protests of course it's a good place to
start
um so for those who don't know how did
these current protests that are going on
at the moment start and where are they
now what is the current status
sure so um the protests uh were in
response or were catalyzed by the murder
of uh Masa amini a 22 year old Iranian
girl who was murdered by the so-called
morality police of the regime for
improper hijab now the maso's death uh
masos murder catalyzed the protests
which quickly transformed into
anti-regime unrest and the point I want
to highlight here I think this is really
important before we start what is going
on in Iran today should not be
surprising it has been clear for years
that the Iranian people want regime
change not reform regime change
um but unfortunately the West was
completely blindsided to this by almost
exclusively focusing on the 2015 nuclear
agreements
um and Trump's withdrawal of that
agreement uh so all the signs were there
but the West uh was was had Tunnel
Vision on on the nuclear agreement now
if we take a step back again
there was a new trend of unrest that
began in Iran in 2017. uh crucially this
trend of unrest took place uh when the
US was still part of the nuclear
agreement and 11 months before sanctions
were reimposed now these protests that
began in 2017 were distinctively
anti-regime in nature so what we're
seeing today is a continuation of that
Trend and this is complete constantly
Spilled Out over onto the Iranian
streets in November 2019 so bloody
November as it is known among Iranians
we saw the regime kill as many as 1 500
civilians in just a few days and that
took place by the way under the
presidency of Hassan Rouhani and his
foreign minister jabod zarif the
so-called moderates or who were painted
out to be moderates to the West that was
the final nail in the coffin for the
so-called moderate uh uh or reformist
camp in the Islamic Republic
it was clear to the Iranian people that
for 30 years they've been lied to and
there is no such thing as reform of the
Islamic public and that's why what we
see today is explicitly about regime
change
okay and this is just the latest symptom
of a much more broader dissatisfaction
with the the regime
um and Casual I'd like to come back to
you in just a moment because I want to
underscore what you just said by hearing
from the United Nations special reporter
on Iran who has called for an
international mechanism to investigate
the state's crimes and hold perpetrators
to account Javed Rayman said there must
be accountability and the International
Community must take action let's listen
how many times can you brutalize people
how many times can you violate their
fundamental human rights their
fundamental dignity and in this uh
series of protests in these were this
wave of protests there is there is a
there is a real issue what about women
and girls of Iran they have stood up
these are young people who are out on
the streets women do not want to be
oppressed and subjugated they are young
bright intelligent women
and now let's turn to one of the key
players in the suppression of the
protests the Islamic revolutionary guard
Corps is a branch of the Iranian armed
forces the irgcs is known Works to
consolidate and reinforce the Iranian
government's control of the country but
that's not all the U.S labeled the irgc
as one of the most powerful economic
actors in Iran with a network of front
companies all over the world from
construction car manufacturing even
laser eye surgery the irgc is involved
in virtually every sector of the Iranian
economy
so just to continue on that line of
questioning then the irgc is a security
enforcing arm of the Iranian government
why is it involved in so many of these
economic activities
I actually think the the uh a more
accurate uh description of what the irgc
is is that the Revolutionary guard is
the is an ideological organization
and an ideological organization that
operates uh as a state within a state it
has its own economic arm it has its own
political arm it has its own military uh
and militia uh so if we look at the
Revolutionary Guard from the eyes of the
clergy and from the eyes of supreme
leader of the Islamic Republic he
regards the irgc as the main pillar of
the Islamic revolution they are the
force that have the willingness and the
resources to forcefully impose uh
ayatollah's Hardline islamist order on
the Iranian people and expand that
overseas so this idea of exporting the
Islamic revolution which has remained
consistent by the way since 1979 for
over four decades now the irgc has been
exporting Terror it has been nurturing
Shia militancy across the Middle East it
has created some of the most deadly
terrorist groups in the world such as
Hezbollah in Lebanon and it was crucial
to uh the suppression of Syrian
civilians for example in the Syrian
Civil War so the irgc aided Bashar
al-assad and Vladimir Putin's
suppression in Syria in terms of its
economic involvement that's absolutely
correct the irgc controlled roughly at
the very least I would say 40 of the
Iranian economy now what is the purpose
of this what's the goal of the irgc well
first and foremost it's an ideological
organization which has clear ideological
goals and these are by the way mandated
in the Islamic Republic's Constitution
the irgc has a official mission of jihad
uh to spread Sharia law across the world
and that's in the Iranian Constitution
the constitution of the Islamic Republic
currently so it's purpose it's economic
activities first fund this it's it's
it's it's ideological objectives whether
that's increasing its resources to
forcefully impose this Hardline islamist
order on the Iranian people or whether
it's exporting the Islamic revolution
funding terrorist groups like Hezbollah
in Lebanon for example
Hezbollah in Lebanon Hassan nasrola the
Secretary General Lebanese Hezbollah
clearly said that the Islamic Republic
pays for every single penny of Hezbollah
and we saw that just recently last year
the Islamic Republic
increased that funding to one billion
dollars annually despite all the
economic uh economic pressures so the
first objective of the Revolutionary
Garden revolutionary guard is the
vehicle to do that
is to fund its ideological activities
abroad the second
purpose of its economic activities
is corruption
the Islam Republic is no different to
that of Putin's regime it is an
oligarchic kleptocratic regime that is
corrupt to its core and the irgc is part
of that it is part of that DNA for
example Muhammad
who is an irgc Commander currently uh
speaker of the Iranian Parliament when
he was mayor of Tehran he embezzled two
billion dollars by Contracting uh
subcontracting contracts to
revolutionary guard entities two billion
dollars were embezzled by barley buff
this gives you a bit of a an insight as
to what the irgc is it is an ideological
extremist organization that is corrupt
to its cause so that roughly captures
what what it's got what its purpose is
but not only that it's important to
understand that we often hear about the
so-called deep state in Iran and and
it's but we so we we highlight the
Revolutionary guard and the clerical
clerical Elites but they also have
created what we can call and what
academics like Professor side golcar has
has referred to as a deep Society the
Islamic Republic does not uh distinguish
between
um it's it's between people in Iran by
nationality rather it distinguishes
between insiders and Outsiders so
nationality becomes irrelevant uh they
do not care about Iran or being Iranian
it's whether you are an Insider or an
outsider insiders are supporters of the
regime and you can be an Insider you can
be a Insider in in Lebanon you can be an
Insider uh in in Iraq Syria and be
supportive of the Islam Republic they
are the ones who are classed as insiders
Outsiders are those who are opposed to
the regime and they can be they are you
know Iranians who oppose the regime are
considered as Outsiders now what this
economy that they have created does it
provides lights for that deep society
which includes which encompasses all the
Insiders so there's a they've created a
working class middle class and upper
class for themselves this deep society
and the rest of the Iranian population
are irrelevant they are Outsiders and
not only that so this economy is to fund
that but the Revolutionary guard is also
teaching its recruits through a program
of indoctrination the Iranians who
oppose the regime these Outsiders if
they act they must be tortured before
their death so any form of dissent
against the Islamic Republic is
considered as being enemy an enemy of
God and muharab and then irgc is
teaching its recruits to torture uh
these people before their death that is
in the internal training manuals the
Revolutionary guard uses to radicalize
its recruits is quite comprehensive
description there so thank you very much
for that so the Revolutionary guard is
ideological political and violent as
well as promoting corruption inside the
country
um there's also a lot of that I want to
touch on uh from what you said there um
there's an element of economic populism
to its work as well so funding job
placements scholarships and things like
that what is the purpose of it I would
actually fit into what you said about
indoctrination
I would actually
um counter that in saying the concept of
populism once seeks to appeal to
ordinary ordinary masses the irgc's
purpose is not to appeal to ordinary
masses the irgc's appeal and focus is on
a very narrow aspect of Iranian Society
namely uh the supporters of the Islamic
Republic and the overming majority of
Iranians reject this regime reject this
ideology and want regime change we're
seeing this on the streets of Iran today
the irgc and the Islamic Republic as a
whole
seeks to appeal to that hard line small
base that it has why well it wants to
give rewards to this base to this small
base no bigger than than 20 of the
Iranian population it wants to appeal
and that's being generous to them it
wants to appeal to this base because by
appealing to this base and drawing them
further in it then reinforces this with
indoctrination and they become part of
that deep society that is critical to
sustaining the regime why is it critical
to sustaining the regime because
that base is the base that will be used
to violently suppress Iranians on the
streets
so Harmony system the entire system of
the Islamic Republic and the irgc has
made Bastion to achieve this is relied
on the violent suppression of ordinary
Iranians by keeping a small extremist
uh constituency alive to suppress the
masses they do that for a number of ways
and one of the incentives to maintain
that extremist Hardline base the
hezbollahi base as we call it in Farsi
is through such economic incentives
um and if you like that's you know
giving allocations privileges in
University giving privileges in terms of
contracts and really making sure that
you know if the irgc is conducting
controlling the business it only gives
business
so it's sub it only subcontracts to
organizations that are supportive of the
regime everyone else private companies
ordinary Iranians they're excluded from
the system by the way it is sought to
replicate this system abroad in Iraq for
example in Iraq the irgc's heartmore
ambr headquarters Carter malambia
construction headquarters that is the
economic arm of the Revolutionary guard
it has massive projects in Iraq for
example where Iran has the Islam
Republic has a a plethora of Shia
militias that it has created
cultural Ambia the irgc's economic arm
will give contracts to these militias to
ensure that the money that is spent is
kept within that support base and it is
recycled so the purpose is not for the
benefit of the Iranian people or the
people of of of of uh where Iran has the
Islamic Republic has a presence abroad
rather it's just to sustain that
Hardline islamist base
okay yeah I think that's a very
comprehensive well argued point there
about the revolution regard but I'd like
us um to look at some other aspects of
Iran as well and the protests are taking
place against a backdrop of serious
economic decline
um as we can see here in 2011 gross
domestic product that's the value of all
goods and services produced was at 626
billion dollars last year it was only
241 billion now that's partly due to the
sanctions imposed by the West as a
result of Iran's nuclear program
um but cancer how do economic factors
like this feed into the protests
well look let's make it absolutely clear
what we're seeing today on the streets
of Iran is not about sanctions it's not
about uh the 2015 nuclear agreement
rather it is about life under an
authoritarian misogynistic kleptocratic
regime that is corrupt to its core
a poll conducted in 2021 so last year uh
where Iranians were asked what is to
blame for uh for the economic uh
situation in in Iran 86 blamed
corruption and mismanagement only 9.7 uh
blame sanctions and uh foreign foreign
pressure
so this goes back to the issue of
corruption and the elite corruption that
we see Iranians are fed up of seeing uh
their lives ruined not only does the
Islamic Republic impose a hard-line
islamist order on them forcefully via
entities like the Revolutionary guards
but the elites their sons their
daughters the agazadas as we call them
in Farsi or the nobleborn
their sons and their daughters live
lavish lifestyles in Western capitals
like London New York and Paris at this
at the same time when the Revolutionary
guard and carmenai's regime enforce a
Hardline uh islamist order on the
Iranian people so corruption is at the
root of this and we see this
of course the economic situation in Iran
is is higher annual food inflation has
increased by almost 100 now but look at
the regime's priorities
um the Islamic Republic despite being uh
you know under immense economic pressure
or at least the people are under immense
economic pressure it has prioritized its
ideological objectives uh over the needs
of the Iranian population it's done that
for 43 years
um I gave you the example earlier on
despite the fact that you know Iran
faces this
um economic hardship they've just
increased the Islamic Republic's just
increased funding to Hezbollah in
Lebanon increased that to 1 billion
sources on the ground in Lebanon uh tell
me that
um the Revolutionary guard has told
Hezbollah operatives that once sanctions
are ease if there is a re-entry to the
2015 nuclear agreement they will be paid
in dollars rather than local currency so
we have to underscore that this regime
has consistently prioritized its
ideological objectives over that of the
needs of the Iranian people not only
that while it enforces this Hardline
islamist order on the Iranian people and
while the Iranians leave on live under
economic um dire economic situations the
sons of the elites the daughters of the
elites the families of the elites live
lavish Lifestyles using the Iranian
people's money abroad uh and in across
the West in Western capitals as I said
the Islamic Republic is very similar to
that of Putin's regimes uh regime uh
it's kleptocratic it's oligarchic and
it's corrupt to its core
yeah and yet they strike out at anyone
else to blame the United States uh even
DW was sanctioned uh by Iran this week
BBC Persian has been branded a terrorist
organization for telling the truth to
Iranians um clearly they'll look at
anyone else to blame but just to
summarize on that point before we talk
about corruption a little bit more
detail about the economic situation it's
not just the fall in GDP we have falling
living standards devalued currency
that's tumbled nearly 90 in the past
five years the cost of goods and
services Rising well over a thousand
percent in the past decade and the
number of women in work decreasing by a
fifth I mean it's it's clearly terrible
for the people who live there um and as
you said I mean it's it's it's the
government failing time and time again
to prioritize its people instead
prioritizing its own ideology
um and it's not just
um the sanctions and all of this that
you've uh you've just discussed already
um that the economic mismanagement is
key there so aside from the corruption
is there incompetency at the heart of
the way that Iran is a man is managing
its economy
oh of course there's incompetency
because this is an ideological regime
all those that are competent that have
the ability to transform Iran into a
successful thriving modern economy there
have they've all been imprisoned because
they do not follow the ideology of this
hard line is the mystery
um there are plenty of Iranians that can
transform Iran into a modern economy
um no different to that of uh across the
Persian Gulf of the UAE no different to
the UAE
um but the reason that potential has not
been achieved is because the Islamic
Republic has purged and imprisoned all
of the intellectuals that can do that
because it prioritizes ideological
commitment over technical expertise this
happened from the very beginning by the
way in 1979 the clerical establishment
the Shia is the Mist rejected the idea
of uh technocratic and bureaucratic
technocratic expertise
um they regarded that as being Western
um and incompatible with an Islamic
Society the Islamic Society they wanted
to forcefully achieve that resulted in a
purge Mass executions imprisonments and
they've maintained that consistently
in Iran at the moment if you you to to
to to achieve uh obtain a position uh
you have to go under ideological tests
they they do ideological assessments to
see how aligned you are with the with
the Islamic Republic's islamist values
if you're not aligned you don't get the
position not only that if you are vocal
against uh the way things are done in
the Islamic Republic this corrupt regime
you're imprisoned you're detained you're
tortured there's a huge history of this
so and that's why by the way the Iranian
people have made it clear you cannot
reform the Islamic Republic
uh for 30 years uh they're you know the
West has been looking towards this
constructed this manufactured uh
hardliner reformist dichotomy that was
created by Harmony
um to alleviate pressure on on the
regime and it's not delivered for 30
years the project of so-called reformism
has failed it was a lie and that's why
Iranians are on the street they are
calling for the downfall of it of the
Islamic Republic in its entirety because
Iran cannot achieve its potential its
full potential on any level if it's
under the Islam Republic not only that
the people of Iran cannot be free
um women cannot be free religious
minorities cannot be free
um gay people cannot be free
um it's really that that is the message
of the Iranian people that's why they're
on the streets uh calling for the for
the downfall of the Islam Republic
but of course it is an extremely
dangerous time as well when we look at
uh when regime change of changes have
happened in the past there's a power
vacuum and you don't know what's going
to fill it and when it comes to the
protests I am wondering where all of
this could go will it be repeat of the
repression of the protest in 2009 or
will it go as far as the uprising
against the Shire in 1979 well what do
you think where do you see all of this
going
well look on the nature of the
protesters it's absolutely clear that
this protest movement that we're seeing
cross country is secular in nature and
it's looking towards establishing a
democratic Iran now what we're
witnessing I think is really the
beginning of the end of the Islamic
Republic the beginning of the end for
Harmony's regime now what happens uh in
the future well look
I think the what as I said the direction
we're going towards it's the beginning
of the end for harmonize regime you know
when that moment happens it could be
weeks it could be months it could be
years uh it is largely dependent on a
few factors among them first of all the
regime's appetite to spill blood which
we know is High
um you know the ayatollah's regime is
not like the the monarchy of uh my
madrasa Levy who when the people took to
the streets decided to leave they will
stay and they will and they will they
will violently suppress those on the
streets just as they did by the way in
Syria in in Syria that was
um in many ways a training ground for
for revolutionary guard members uh to to
learn methods to suppress unarmed
civilians on the streets because the
clergy by the way was very aware that
this was going to happen in Iran and
but if we take a step back what is this
the product of of we have seen this gap
between the state and Society in Iran
reach unprecedented levels
uh Iran has experienced a gradual
process of secularization and
liberalization Iranian Society not the
regime Iranian society as experiences
this began in the early 1990s and really
it's manifested itself on the streets
and we can track the growth of this
secularization and liberalization by
monitoring the protests and how they
have grown so the trend of unrest in
Iran reveals that protests are growing
in size in scale and the regime is
having to use more violence to suppress
them so in 1999 the first wave of
anti-rangement unrest that took place in
three cities and seven Iranians were
killed fast forward to 2009 a decade on
we saw protests in around 10 cities and
um 100 Iranians were killed by the
regime a decade on in November 2019 we
see protest anti-regime unrest in over
100 towns and cities and 1 500 Iranians
were killed in just a few days
the protest we're seeing today right now
we see these this the other this unrest
in virtually every Iranian Province so
this is really a product of the gap
between the state and Society it's
unsustainable for the regime to preserve
it but it relies on first of all
appetite to spill blood secondly the
resource the capacity of the
Revolutionary guard and third a third
factor that can influence the timeline
as to as to when this regime collapses
is international support for the
protesters and consequences imposed on
on Harmony's regime so for example it's
very clear and Harmony has acknowledged
that you know
the Iranian people want regime change so
any sanctions relief given to the
Islamic Republic will not be used to
alleviate pressure on the Iranian people
rather it will be used to bolster the
Revolutionary garden and the forces that
suppress them on the Iranian streets
that's one point
another way the West uh can can play an
influential role in supporting the
protesters is
treating uh the regime's oligarchs in
the same way that the West has treated
Putin's oligarchs
targeting uh the elites corrupt Elite
abroad freezing their assets imposing
travel bans and that will make Harmony
feel and his regime feel the
consequences of their actions uh and
finally a third way the International
Community can support the Iranian
protesters and impose again real
consequences that we felt by Harmony's
regime is targeting the Revolutionary
guard and prescribing the Revolutionary
guard as a terrorist organization the
irgc operates no different to the likes
of Isis or Al-Qaeda listed groups
already the irgc uses a program of
indoctrination that is extremist
islamist and violent in nature it is
teaching its recruits to not only wage
Jihad against Jews Christians and
zoroastrians but it is teaching its
recruits to torture and kill Iranians
who oppose this regime and we're seeing
that on the streets of Iran today the
irgc has also been involved in Terror
rest operations for the past 43 years
one way to send a clear message to
Harmony's regime and impose real
consequences for the Revolutionary guard
is listing it as a terrorist
organization this was done by the U.S it
has been supported by the Biden industry
Biden Administration Biden has kept the
irgc on the terror list I think it's
it's time for European States uh to
follow suit
okay so there's definitely a lot more
that the International Community in the
west needs to do they need to step up
that was a powerful and damning
indictment
um of the Iranian regime thank you very
much that's all we have time for but I'd
like to thank Our Guest kazra Arabi that
was a a really eloquent and well put
description of the situation in Iran at
the moment and thank you for watching if
you want more you can follow me on
Twitter at winterbizz and you can catch
more videos from DW business here on
YouTube bye for now
foreign